[Music]
Gotha is an entire subculture which
inspired not only decades of music but
fashion and films in fact the unique
look associated with goth culture is as
much a part of the brand as its
melancholy music their country has its
belt buckles and boots goth has it
stripped pants and chains but we want to
know what came first
was it the new D fashion or was it the
music so we're not talking about the Hot
Topic Moll Goths this was something that
came straight out of the late 70s
post-punk scene
it was a dark moody black lipstick
wearing Spectre known as God Rock Goths
influence can be seen everywhere from
Jim Burton movies to Billie Eilish
there's even an annual goth cruise today
la and I are going to embrace our inner
Goths put on the black mascara and
lipstick and create an appropriately
moody song but first we're going to talk
about where the subculture really
started so aside from the silver jewelry
and black jeans
what exactly is gone firstly we need to
get into the vibe by reading Edgar Allen
Poe why let's look it up now no doubt I
now grew very pale but I talked more
fluently and with a heightened voice
villains I shrieked the cymbal no more I
admit the deed to help the planks here
here is the beating of his hideous heart
start
while the term gothic originally came
about to describe European architecture
of the Middle Ages from roughly the 12th
century through the 16th the term was
later used to describe romantic and
spooky literature from the 17 and 1800's
so what does I have to do with the Moody
musical style most give credit to music
critic John Stickney for connecting the
term with the music after meeting Jim
Morrison of the doors in a gloomy wine
cellar in 1967 he wrote that it was the
perfect room to honor the Gothic rock of
the doors referencing the similar lyrics
and dark musical stylings of the band
this is the
but by the late 70s and early 80s goth
rock was a genre where did goth rock
come from it's considered to be an
offshoot of the late 70s British punk
rock scene called post-punk post-punk to
the energy and the do-it-yourself spirit
of punk and bold experimental New
Directions
blending Punk with influences from other
genres like disco funk and electronic
music while Punk was considered an angry
rebel yell at the establishment
Goffman came the opposite a fatalistic
romantic resignation to the inevitable
during this time three bands really came
to the forefront of the emerging genre
to become the pioneers of the goth rock
movement Joy Division Siouxsie and the
Banshees and Bauhaus so what made these
goth bands so gothic gothic is often
identified by its dark themes and is
considered nihilistic and poetic a
recurring heavy bass a moody synthesizer
and the use of echo doesn't hurt either
perhaps what can be considered as the
archetype for all goth music was Bauhaus
a single Bela Lugosi's dead which came
out in 1979 is considered by many to be
the first truly gothic rock song
[Music]
Lugosi was an actor who played the title
character in universe was 1931 film
Dracula and whose real life was almost
as tragic as his fictional one the
band's bassist David J said he came up
with the idea for the song and wrote it
after binge watching vampire movies on
television the band's frontman Peter
Murphy said the sound of the song was in
part also inspired by dub reggae you can
hear the influence listen to the
revolutionaries reaction and dub from
1978
and here's Bela Lugosi's dead Mouse's
song may be considered gods first anthem
but it was just the beginning for the
musical genre the English band Siouxsie
and the Banshees performed in 1976
taking their name from the horror movie
cry of the Banshee which start another
classic of horror Vincent Price some
argue Siouxsie and the Banshees was
originally a punk band that transitioned
to post punk goth with her fourth album
junior in
[Music]
but there's no debate that lead singer
Suzie Suh heavily influenced goth
fashion but more on that later other
bands such as Joy Division the Sisters
of Mercy the Cure the dance Dead Can
Dance Type O Negative and many more put
on their capes and came out of the
shadows with their dark messages of
loneliness and rebellion so what exactly
are we getting ourselves into listen I
thought about goth initially I thought
was gonna be super similar to the metal
thing I'm like okay it's gonna be a lot
of work okay got a dig in but then here
and actually like goth rock music it
puts me in an era early 80s it sounds
exactly like that where this is the
sense were like longing you like I don't
know if this is a thing throughout but a
lot of open intervals even if we're not
dealing with an unstable harmony like an
Augmented chord but still just something
about this open sound it feels like it
doesn't really need to resolve anywhere
or go anywhere but it also doesn't feel
like it's settled
if you had to resolve that kind of had
to resolve that where would you go
[Music]
you've got anywhere okay so we know
where the music started can we assume
that the fashion and style began about
the same time it may have begun much
earlier goth was directly inspired by
the romanticism of both the romantic and
Victorian era drawing some of its
earliest inspirations from Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein the writings of
Edgar Allan Poe and Bram Stoker but
oddly enough the beginnings of the goth
style may have actually had its roots in
the Victorian tuberculosis epidemic the
gaunt and pale look of those affected by
the fatal disease was often romanticized
influencing the mid-1800s perceptions of
beauty which were later adopted by the
emerging goth culture horror cinema also
inspired Gothic style silent film star
theta Berra was nicknamed the vamp and
French actress Sarah Bernhardt was known
for sleeping in a coffin later there was
pinup model Bettie Page Vampira actress
Milan Urmi and of course TVs Elvira goth
was further cemented in popular culture
in 1976 with Anne Rice's interview with
a vampire
a novel believed to have also held in
fluent the Shinra but now back to Susie
suit the godmother of goth a raven hair
and signature i make that was more
influenced by ancient Egyptians than the
Victorians
but once the style was off the gate it
took on an afterlife of its own the goth
culture as we know it today further
developed in 1982 with opening of the
London goth club the bat cave the club
inspired the spooky scene with regular
performances from Bauhaus Siouxsie and
the Banshees as well as many others soon
goth spread across the globe infecting
many with its dark music and
are you ready to embrace your inner goth
let's get it on with it like this I got
a bass at the crib and so I could
definitely lay the hell yes I'm all for
LA playing bass guitar tempo wise even
if we have like going up top we could
have like yes boom they're still driving
is still marching but it's like you're
walking you're not walking down a sunny
Street you're walking in the woods that
kind of has to just sound like we're
getting in a dark crevice in our
headline okay I want to add some
textures there has to be that fuzz they
twisted it up some way somehow there's a
lot of sound design with them Sam's okay
I think we have a fun
gonna know more about creatures of the
night we'll head over to monstrum a PBS
show all about monsters myths and
folklore hosted by our friend dr. Z an
expert of all things gothic
you
[Music]